do you have something you need to be
doing right now but are avoiding like
the plague maybe you have a lot of stuff
you need to do but you just keep putting
it off and you distract yourself from
the discomfort of even thinking about it
have you ever thought about what it
would feel like if you actually
completed all of it like you just took a
day from the moment you woke up to the
end of the day you worked hard through
motivation and determination and just
crushed everything on your to-do list
today we're going to talk about that I'm
Joey and welcome to better ideas
[Music]
being massively productive over a long
period of time can seem like an activity
that many people lack the motivation or
focus to pull off but what a lot of
people don't realize is they don't
actually lack motivation or focus
they're just not setting the right
parameters to foster an environment of
productivity and focus in order to have
a day where you're massively productive
from start to finish you have to set
yourself up for success so here are five
techniques that I use when I really need
to get stuff done and when I use them
together I noticed I'm just far more
focused far more motivated and I
actually end up crushing everything on
my to-do list also disclaimer these
techniques work best for home work
office work paperwork anything where you
can sit down at a coffee shop or at a
desk number one find your sacred space
the sacred space is your particular
geographical location that you treat
with the utmost respect
it's your temple of productivity it
could be a particular coffee shop that
you notice that you work really well in
or it could even be a certain corner in
your house that you notice the ears have
extra focus in you just have to make
sure that when you're there it's for
studying and studying only once you goof
off in that spot you've officially
desecrated the sacred place and it's no
longer sacred you have to find a
different place you ruined it my second
technique is start your work first thing
in the morning if you're really serious
about getting work done that day and
it's really important to you don't check
social media first thing in the morning
don't go on your phone just go to the
sacred space as soon as possible and
start hitting the books and getting to
work as I've mentioned in previous
videos willpower is a finite resource
that depletes with every single decision
you make throughout the day so in the
morning you have an abundant amount of
willpower that you can use at your
disposal so just channel that glorious
amount of willpower and just hyper focus
it into being productive step number
three is to make a proper checklist you
need a road map as to where you're going
and making a good checklist is a lot
more than just writing all your tasks in
random order and putting a little tick
box next to them you have to organize
prioritize and streamline every single
thing on that list into its most basic
component I get into a lot more detail
on how exactly to make this checklist in
a previous video I'll put the link in
the description number four is to use
the Pomodoro Technique
Doro technique I don't really know how
to pronounce Pomodoro Pomodoro Pomodoro
totara so basically you work for 25
minutes and take a 5-minute break doing
some type of non mentally hyperactive
activity this reduces the amount of
mental strain associated with high
levels of a concentration and allows you
to work harder for longer technique
number 5 is to set a final alarm to the
particular time that you need to start
thinking about something else
now this one seems kind of obvious but a
lot of people in the collect it and
don't really realize its importance I
know in my own life when I have a
meeting or a class sometime late at
night and I'm trying to get homework
done earlier in that day I'm always
thinking of that looming thing I have to
do and not all my attention is focused
on my present work so in order to have
the most effective work session you have
to really free up things like that free
up mental ramp don't think about the
things you have to do in the future just
focus on the now so that's what you have
to delegate the mental RAM or your
responsibilities to things like alarms
so once you set that in place you don't
have to worry about it anymore
you can focus a hundred percent of your
attention on the task at hand and really
get things done and hone your focus most
people are familiar with the lease one
of these techniques but very few people
use all of them at the same time and the
people I do know who have incorporated
three or more of these things into their
daily work routine are some of the most
productive people I've ever met so give
it a try maybe you have a dark cloud of
looming responsibilities hanging over
you causing me to be stressed anxious
whatever well by properly utilizing
these techniques and incorporating them
in your study or work session you can be
sure that your focus will be honed your
productivity game will be off the charts
so you can chip away at that mountain of
responsibilities until it's a little
pile of dust lying at the feet of you
the victor if you like this video and
want to see me make more be sure to hit
that subscribe button down below too
and if you have any ideas for future
videos or requests or suggestions or
anything at all leave it in the comment
section below I'd be happy to answer
also follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter Facebook one is better ideas TV
the Instagram is better ideas daily and
the Twitter is also better ideas TV yeah
I was right catch you in the next video